Mexico's president Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador wants his country to be energy
independent
in the coming year we will not purchase
gasoline diesel or overall products
abroad
to fulfill his promise of energy
self-sufficiency president Lopez obrador
has doubled down on investments in
domestic oil and gas production
favoring the country's state-owned
producers over foreign private
Enterprise when it comes to Mexico's
energy sector
this protectionist energy policy experts
say has come at the expense of a trade
dispute between Mexico and its northern
neighbors
the problem is rooted in deals made
under the free trade agreement between
the U.S Canada and Mexico agreements
specific to generating energy
critics say Mexico's energy policies
have also slowed progress on renewable
energy undermining North American Energy
integration and competitiveness for his
part Mexican president Andres Manuel
Lopez obrador has pledged that 35
percent of all energy consumed in Mexico
will come from clean and renewable
sources by the year 2024. earlier this
year president Lopez obrador announced
the launch of a 1.6 billion dollar solar
farm in the Sonoran Desert the largest
of its kind in Latin America
the president has also announced plans
for 10 new industrial parks that will
harness wind energy along Mexico's
trans-ismic corridor
while critics say president Lopez
obrador's seemingly contradictory
attitude some have even called it double
speak when it comes to fossil fuels and
renewable energy has put the country at
an energy Crossroads policy experts
instead argue that pressure from the
United States under the U.S Mexico
Canada Free Trade Agreement or usmca has
forced Mexico to slowly open its doors
to private investment
horizontal under private companies and
the functions that could arrive from all
of this have led Mexico to change course
though current policies in Mexico have
prioritized energy Independence
nationally experts warn that it's
critical for Mexico to look Beyond its
political disagreements with the U.S and
Canada for the sake of a more integrated
North American Energy Market one that
can also meet the Region's long-term
goals for sustainability
Al Jazeera Mexico City